how I'm using a camera Oh professor
Nakamura thank you very much for
speaking to us and congratulations on
the award okay thank you so can you tell
me where were you when you heard the
news a nice way to be woken up what was
your initial reaction on hearing the
news I win the Nobel Prize do you know
because basically physics means survive
people was our data for the invention of
the basic theory you know but the images
are not the basic theory
imagine that making the device you know
so I'm not sure who is like between
Nobel Prize not better but another
committee called me and you got the
Nobel Prize that's enough that's very
nice and very humble of you but your
device is everywhere now
one cannot move but for finding LEDs
everywhere so how do you feel now that
your invention is ubiquitous my device
is every night it is everywhere to you
know to save energy you know so I am
very happy enough everything I could in
my are LED and the desire and they happy
did you ever imagine it would become so
important no way I started the mighty
but I never figure I could be inventor
an idiot of the day as well I never but
people said that it would be in very
very hard to make a blue LED and what
gave you the courage to continue and
make it happen
I
quiz you know already has a problem and
I have to solve the problem so I know
the pattern just like I decide to like
turn up in the quiz so open from a
hopper I wanted to tell of the problem
and so that I continue to posit are
using those affair so the Milka I like
decide so that is the reason and what
what advice do you have for students who
are just starting out what do you write
what I write you know and almost it's
like a dream and then just you know what
work hard for your dream I think it does
now it's it's the middle of the night
there in Canada will you get any sleep
at all tonight we're going to call it 3
a.m. and there are no time for even no
time for that are you enjoying yourself
yes good well for now let me just wish
you all congratulations on your prize
good luck with everything that's gonna
happen tonight
ok thank you very much